today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
alright so of course we have to start
today with joe biden selecting
california democratic senator kamala
harris to be his running mate yesterday
later in the day
uh speculation sort of building we were
supposed to hear around
august 1st august 1st came and went
august 8th came and went
the convention starts in just days so it
was time and we did hear that indeed
senator kamala harris is going to be joe
biden's running mate
this makes her the first woman of color
to ever
be a vp or presidential nominee although
as many of you know i don't particularly
focus on identity type stuff but it's
certainly relevant and i'm going to talk
about it uh
more um obviously this pick
immediately set off a cascade of
criticism from some on the left and of
course the right immediately going into
uh all sorts of attacks on kamala
harris's character and joe biden's
character donald trump
saying uh horrible things about her
during yesterday's press briefing which
we're going to look at but that those
those are sort of details right the
monday morning quarterbacking
uh and the rest of it are are not where
i want to start
let's look at the pros and cons of
kamala harris first and i'm going to go
directly first to the worst of kamala
and work backwards from there
but before i do that there are people
who are writing to me and who i'm seeing
on twitter and other places saying this
is a terrible pick david this is
who could possibly be worse than kamala
harris any other person or at least this
person or that person would have been
better
every one of the supposed finalists had
problems and i think that it's important
at this point
not to um fallaciously imagine
that anybody who we might be able to
pick out of a hat
could have been better because most of
those people weren't actually being
considered the people reasonably being
considered
were by joe biden's own selection
narrowing a woman
increasingly pointing to a woman of
color although
joe biden never really said that but you
might remember when amy klobuchar
removed her name from consideration even
though it had already been removed due
to her association
um in in minneapolis related to derek
shavin
uh the man who who killed george floyd
amy klobuchar on her way out said
it should be a woman of color etc so
being able to say well what about this
person who was never even really up for
consideration that's not the way
politics works we might like it to work
that way but it doesn't
in terms of the people who seem to be
finalists if biden goes with elizabeth
warren
according to some that's a problem
because elizabeth warren is not a person
of color
according to others elizabeth warren
would have been a problem because she's
too liberal others would say well
elizabeth warren is a northeasterner and
that's not
what joe biden needs right now or
whatever biden picks susan rice
it's pandering to obama supporters or
it's bad because susan rice is
associated with benghazi and the
republicans are going to seize on that
or whatever
the point is some group would find
something supposedly terrible about any
one of the people that was
being considered and the trump campaign
would find
something to seize on no question so we
can't really go by that in our analysis
now kamala harris's biggest liability
certainly is her role as attorney
general of california
executing the war on drugs and it was a
disaster
it is the exact opposite of what the
democratic party should be moving
towards
republicans are going to hit her with it
and they're going to hit biden with it
they will say
we already know they will do it donald
trump has done
lots for black people he signed the
first step
act he's commuted to send the unfair
drug sentences of
you know list of people and meanwhile
biden is picking kamala harris they're
going to do it
and okay that'll be something that has
to be dealt with now
on the upsides to kamala harris
it depends on what's most important to
you but there's a few angles here
number one kamal is 55 years old
she's far younger than elizabeth warren
but most importantly she's way younger
than both biden
and trump and certainly brings an energy
and a dynamic to this race that is
completely missing
on the republican side and quite frankly
was missing uh with just joe biden on
the democratic side
as well if you believe that our leaders
should be younger than what we've been
seeing
lately um then this is a positive for
kamala harris number two
harris is a senator in california so if
biden wins and becomes vice president
that open senate seat in california will
be filled by democratic governor
gavin newsom until there's a special
election why does that matter
if it had been elizabeth warren who was
selected
republican governor of massachusetts
charlie baker
gets to pick a replacement and he picks
a republican and when you're looking at
a senate
in the fall where it's conceivable that
democrats could take control
and if they do it might only be by one
the last thing you want
is to lose one of those seats because
elizabeth warren leaves and then charlie
baker picks a republican so i think that
that's
relevant now in terms of debating kamala
harris is going to absolutely destroy
mike pence
kamala harris a far better debater than
elizabeth warren
for sure kamala harris will make
mincemeat out of mike pence remember
this
incident with william barr thank you mr
chairman attorney general barr has the
president or anyone at the white house
ever asked or suggested that you open an
investigation of anyone
um i wouldn't i wouldn't uh
yes or no could you repeat that question
i will repeat it has the president or
anyone at the white house ever asked or
suggested that you open
an investigation of anyone yes or no
please sir
um the president or anybody
else seems you would remember something
like that and be able to tell us
yeah but i'm trying to grapple with the
word suggest i mean
there have been discussions of of
matters out there that
uh they have not asked me to open a
investigation but perhaps they've
suggested
i don't know i wouldn't say suggest
hinted i don't know
inferred you don't know
okay okay so that that's definitely a
plus
for kamala harris now let's step back
for a moment
a hearty debate about harris versus
whoever else
is great but we should not lose sight of
the reality
that we're it kamala harris who had been
president instead of donald trump when
we were hit with the pandemic
uh this entire country would be
dramatically better off
today kamala harris at the top level
unlike donald trump can think
kamala harris unlike mike pence thinks
for
herself rather than simply being a brown
noser so
i'm certainly not going to allow myself
to be confused or to miss the forest for
the trees and forget that kamala harris
is someone who actually knows things who
can do things
who can function as an executive is
competent and intelligent whereas right
now it's the blind leading the blind
that's what we have right now in the
oval office
she's not as progressive as i would like
okay and i know that there's debate over
this
trump said yesterday during his press
briefing that she's the the most liberal
senator
um and of course uh now i would consider
bernie sanders to be takamala harris's
left
elizabeth warren to be to kamala harris
is left it is true that a few years ago
kamala was ranked according to one
ranking
as the most left member of the senate
that's good
in my mind but certainly today when you
look at specific
uh positions on uh healthcare for
example okay she's not the most left
uh but i'm not gonna lose sight of i'm
not gonna lose the forest for the trees
now one other really interesting thing
to think about
joe biden choosing kamala harris is sort
of the antithesis of how donald trump
operates and i tweeted about this
yesterday and a lot of people seem to
react
positively generally i would say when
people come
at donald trump when people confront
trump
when people publicly say things about
trump
that they disagree with even people in
trump's own party
trump's reaction is to ostracize them
call them out publicly and cut them out
while assailing their character because
his
skin is so thin joe biden took
his toughest critic from the democratic
primary and the debates i mean
the biggest conflicts during the primary
were between joe biden and kamala harris
and
he put her next to him on the ticket
like him
or not like her or not this alone
is all the evidence i know i need to
know that this is a team that i would
choose over trump pence any day these
are adults
biden has been through so much in his
life it's a joke
to think that someone is going to hurt
his feelings by attacking him
in a debate and he picked her to be
alongside him
on the ticket on the other hand you have
trump born with a silver spoon in his
mouth a complete narcissist and we've
seen how that has played out
with him as president and the answer is
not very well now some of the dumbest
takes
so far i've seen about this selection
one is questioning whether kamala harris
is really black
that's one that i'm seeing over the last
12 16 hours on twitter
uh you know what her dad is jamaican and
jamaicans are not african-american they
are
you know afro-caribbean or something
else altogether really dumb argument
okay
uh she's she's a woman of color
and this sorry she's not really
african-american come on guy that's the
argument
very very dumb and then number two i'm
starting to see
the idea that biden didn't choose her
that the dnc chose her or some shadow
puppet masters maybe jewish bankers in
some cases
chose kamala harris because she's
friendly to banking
come on okay that we're we're not that's
not the direction we're going to go in
here
policy analysis yes uh that that's
we're not going to go in that direction
last thoughts on this for now
the other reason that this choice is a
big deal and i'm not saying this is good
but it's
impactful is that the selection of
kamala harris
sort of sets the democratic party's
course
potentially for a decade or more bill
share wrote about this and you can find
his tweet about it
linking to his article he's bill share
on twitter
and bill share pointed out uh if vice
presidents
choose to run for president
at the end of their vice presidency
so to speak which could be if biden only
goes one term that could be in four
years or it could be in eight years
when vps run in the primary they
essentially always win they almost
always win meaning that uh when joe
biden
picks a vice president he is picking
someone
who would have available to them the
democratic party nomination
in four or eight years kamala harris
strikes me
in particular because of her young age
as someone who would be well suited
to after being vice president if she is
run for president
she is decidedly in the center-left
democratic establishment there's no
denying that we can argue about exactly
where she is on the spectrum of liberal
to to centrist
but she is not part of the populist
socialist
ish insurgency that we saw get behind
bernie sanders she's not in that wing
so if we get four or eight years of
biden
and then kamala if she wants the
nomination
whenever biden steps back or or is
is done if it's eight years she has it
available
we are talking about anywhere between
you know
eight and uh sixteen years
of this type of democratic party a lot
of people are not
happy about that uh and that's something
we're going to be talking about more as
well
but but this is a like it or not this is
a very
consequential selection and a very
consequential
election as well august 23rd
is the 15-year anniversary of the david
pakman show we will be doing a
huge one-day membership special to
commemorate this
i invite you to get on our newsletter at
davidpakman.com you'll be notified
on the 23rd of something very very
special
something i don't think we've ever ever
seen before on the david pakman show
grab
a free newsletter subscription at
davidpakman.com
let me know your thoughts about kamala
harris via twitter
where you can find me at d pacman the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that
i have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
daniel bellan and doug
farren thanks to daniel and doug for
your support
also a big thank you to john rivetti
john's today's longtime sustaining
member of the day john's been a member
for almost five years and you can grab a
membership
for yourself at joinpacman.com
okay it is time for hatred mail hatred
mail is when a professional voice over
artist
interpretively reads the hate mail that
i get a quick reminder about
what hatred mail is now with a whole
slate of new coronavirus related hatred
male introductions
last time i checked this was america and
i have the right to
share my droplets with whoever i want
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate david pakman
because america and because
freedom that's a good one that's a
that's a very good one
uh okay let's get right in to this
week's hatred mail
why doesn't david marry joe biden if he
loves him so much
you are such a fearful little child
pac-man
dude's a corporate skill you have the
lamest political show
on youtube i don't even follow your show
you just proved david pakman that you
are
relatively ignorant your angry caller
jimmy is a hundred percent right and i
have no
idea why i'm still subbed to this tripe
this is a playground thing you know if
you like biden so much you should marry
him because you're gay right i mean it's
these hatreds have regressed or maybe
they never progressed past
sort of like being 10 years old it's
weird and unfortunately many of them are
i know this is crazy but they're in
positions of power uh
in this country come on guys we're
adults here okay biden is good on some
issues he's less good
on other issues he's orders of magnitude
better
than donald trump overall we shouldn't
deify politicians we shouldn't
idolize politicians and by the way
nobody's forcing you to subscribe to me
yes we are on the path
to a million youtube subscribers that's
true but you don't have to be one of
them hopefully we'll get over
the finish line by election day but if
you want to bow
out by all means do what's best for you
i i am confident
um that there are very few of these
haters relative to the people that are
signing up and i think we'll have some
very very big things to announce
from the standpoint of a million coming
to you very soon remember that you can
use the coupon code hatred 40
to get 40 off the membership of your
choice at joinedpakman.com
the spelling very important all lower
case
all one word h a t r i o t
four zero okay so yesterday donald trump
had another one of these coronavirus
press briefings
this one was particularly bad even by
the standards that we've come to
apply to these press briefings and there
was something
trump seemed to sort of just lack energy
he seemed deflated
it was almost like he had the wind taken
out of him
just before coming out to brief the
press he seemed maybe out of gas is the
right analogy
he was disoriented he was confused
during the brief presentation part
when it was time for questions he called
on mostly friendly reporters
some of whom asked ridiculous questions
and then just slowly walked off
after not taking too many questions now
the content is of course really
disturbing
we now have the additional contrast of
biden harris right and we really start
to get the sense
as we think about that and we see the
continued deterioration
that almost anyone almost anyone would
have better dealt with coronavirus than
this
administration these are just not people
up to the task
uh and i want to go through some of
these moments with you now
it's it's almost becoming more sad and
depressing than anything else
in addition to being horrifying that
this is the guy
who's in charge of the country right now
let's start with coronavirus from
yesterday again
an administration just out of ideas no
ideas about what to do
they have come up with what is this
genius talking point
of talking about the percentage
increases in other countries take a look
at this
but the virus continues to increase in
nations across the globe last week
france and germany both recorded their
highest daily number
of new cases in three months
not that i want to bring that up but
might as well
explain it to the media the seven day
case average for germany has increased
by 62 percent since last week
unfortunately and that is truly
unfortunate
it's increased 82 percent in france
113 in spain and 30 percent
in the united kingdom those are big
increases cases are also rapidly
increasing in the netherlands sweden
belgium
switzerland slovakia estonia and
other european countries and in our
country
they're going down now it's important to
note
that the reason trump now talks about
the percentage increases in a lot of
countries
is because the numbers in those
countries are still
tiny compared to our numbers even on a
per capita basis
so trump has to say because otherwise
these would be really dumb things to say
i mean they're dumb anyway but nobody
would fall for them
trump has to say percentage-wise here's
what we're seeing in other countries now
this is important in two ways
number one the reactions
in these other countries are completely
different to in the united states in the
united states we've been
sort of hovering between when we got
down to 20 000 new cases a day
half the country pretended like it was
over we reopened and we got up to nearly
80
000 cases a day we've now come back from
those numbers
so when you never really go down when
you just have a raging pandemic in the
united states for what is now many many
months
percentage-wise you're not going to see
drastic changes because it's just
it's been bad and it remains bad in
these european countries and other
countries they so
successfully dealt with the virus that
once you get down really low even small
increases in terms of the number of
cases
are high increases in terms of
percentage that's one thing to
understand about the the sort of
just arithmetic of it the other piece is
in these other countries as soon as they
started to see these upticks
they immediately say we've got to start
shutting things down
we've got to expand guidelines we have
to tighten and expand
mask wearing etc so when trump
points to this the numbers are deceptive
because of how poorly we dealt with it
when it never got good
it's just going to kind of stay bad and
and even
on a percentage basis but we just
continue plodding along like
idiots collectively obviously many of us
individually are doing the right things
while these other countries immediately
react now the the other
thing i think it's important to mention
is just how small the numbers are in
some of these places you know trump
mentions germany
germany had 436 cases on monday we had
40 000
and even on a per capita adjusted basis
we have so many more cases than the
countries that donald trump is the
these are outbreaks that you can't even
really compare
because they are qualitatively and
quantitatively
so different then trump has become
focused and fixated really almost
obsessed on college football
he wants college football to start now
it's very clear trump knows very little
about sports and doesn't really care
about sports and in fact videos we've
seen of trump watching sports he looks
very
very bored and doesn't really seem to
get sports
but here he is acting like college
football is a really really big thing
that he wants to see happen right away
as we safely restore a great economy and
reopen our schools and hopefully
we can watch colleges play football we
want to get football in colleges
these are young strong people they won't
have a big problem
with the china virus so we want to see
college football start
and hopefully a lot of
great people are going to be out there
they're going to be out there playing
football and
they'll be able to fight it off and
hopefully it won't bother them one bit
most of them will never get it
statistically
but we know we'll see more cases at some
point and
we will eventually develop sufficient
immunity
in addition to everything else that
we're doing so college football get out
there and play football people want to
see it and stand for your american flag
stand for your national anthem because
people are not happy when
that doesn't happen something about the
billionaire president
telling unpaid college athletes to just
go out there and play and that most of
them will be fine
that seems a little bit dystopian to me
and by the way
is is it bad that i've been so
desensitized
to trump calling it the china virus that
i don't even find the need to comment on
that like is that a bad thing that's
going on
uh like it's it's become so pedestrian
almost for him to refer to it that way
that it's barely even worth a mention
and in reality what else is there to say
about it
on the facts by the way multiple college
football players have already started to
develop
heart conditions as a result of catching
coronavirus and so as usual donald trump
is also
wrong on the facts then of course
donald trump mispronounces kamala
harris's name
kamala is concerned she's a now my
fellow
uh battle star galactica fans will
remember that one kamala i believe
was like a drug that people took in
battlestar galactica it's been a little
while since i watched it but fact check
me on that one i think you will find
that i am
i am right more substantively sort of
immediately as expected donald trump
starts attacking kamala harris and
says that she's nasty she's a woman and
she's nasty take a look she had a lot of
things happening and
so i was a little surprised that he
picked her i've been watching her for a
long time and i was a little surprised
she was extraordinarily nasty
to kavanaugh judge kavanaugh then now
justice kavanaugh she was nasty to a
level that was
just a horrible thing the way she was
the way she treated
now justice kavanaugh and i won't forget
that soon
so she did very poorly in the primaries
and now she's chosen so let's see how
that all works
the nasty to kavanagh thing i find
fascinating because she actually had the
strength to question
brett kavanaugh the way he deserved to
be questioned
and you know these these guys like trump
they claim to be
super alpha and powerful and strong
and yet they can't stand up to
questioning trump regularly can't stand
up to questioning from female reporters
and that seems to trigger him way more
than questioning from male reporters
kamala harris
asking good questions of brett kavanaugh
makes her
nasty in trump's mind and this is
definitely a preview of what we can
expect in the campaign from here on out
they're so mean they're so nasty they're
being so horrible to us well
you just don't like it when your
narrative is questioned when your echo
chamber is pierced that's all it is
then trump again just struggling to
speak uh here he keeps repeating
anarchists for some reason
and he keeps repeating it until he gets
it wrong take a listen
they really are anarchists these are
left-wing anarchists
they are anarchists and i'm directing
the department
very strange very strange he also talked
about
plasma rather than plasma although i
won't that's like every day i'm not even
going to play that for you
and then lastly again sort of a very
down
sad trump throwing out some
last smears of kamala harris before
hanging his head and just wandering away
from the podium after taking only a few
questions
or modify it to a point where it's
essentially no longer the second
amendment
i would have thought he would have gone
a different way thank you very much
so what do you think is it does trump
gain anything by doing these press
briefings
uh kellyanne these press briefings
you'll remember
stopped they started slowing down and
then they stopped all together
after the disaster where trump wondered
aloud about maybe injecting bleach or
isopropyl alcohol
in order to treat coronavirus kellyanne
conway then
suggested publicly the reason trump's
approval is down
is he stopped the briefings and he
shortly thereafter restarted them and
you know
what is true is that the polls have been
tightening since he restarted them
causation and correlation are two
different things
and i think we can probably point to
other explanations if we want to look
for them but
is this helping trump to some degree or
is he doing more damage does it not
matter we hear about ratings but at the
same time most of the country is not
watching these
let me know what you think we will have
continued coverage
of the fiasco just ghastly
press briefings on the david pakman show
instagram that's david pakman show
and we also of course every day
have the full hour audio podcast
available
around 3 pm eastern if you prefer a long
form
audio version of the show you don't have
to watch clips on youtube
i love it when you do but if you prefer
the sort of long form audio format that
you can take with you easily
you can subscribe to the daily audio
podcast on
spotify itunes google play really
whatever your favorite podcasting app is
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay let's continue as it's been a very
very busy 24 hours donald trump as i
mentioned
yesterday had this super low energy
coronavirus press briefing it was just
bad he seemed deflated he took only a
few questions mostly from
friendly reporters and then after
smearing kamala harris and
mispronouncing her name he just sort of
stalked off the stage in the way
uh really i've only ever seen donald
trump uh do very very strange
sort of dynamics and posture to it and
of course what comes out of his mouth is
is not much better apparently feeling
like he needed a booster
last night donald trump called into the
sean hannity propaganda program
on fox news to i guess sort of try to
have a better showing than he did
during the press briefing but what's not
been working out super well for trump on
fox news
is that he gets fed the most softball
of softball questions and he still
manages to either
mess it up or say something that
actually
worsens the situation for him and it's
like nobody can make the guy look good
almost nobody
although i'll tell you at the end of
this segment who i do think
manages to make trump look less bad and
trump went on fox news spoke to sean
hannity
last night calling from the white house
up trying to take some of the attention
back from the news cycle of joe biden
selecting kamala harris to be his
running mate and
it was really weird and it was really
bad and once again i have to ask
how is it that these interviews keep
happening again and again and again
clearly we know that the people around
donald trump have no control over him
but also even the friendly interviews go
bad
like even sean hannity who's trump's
friend and is not
interested in anything that we would
call journalism when it comes to donald
trump
even he can't get trump a sensible
interview so let's look at some of these
and hope that in a few months
this type of nonsense from the oval
office because that's what this
is this is not you know some uh as
as some like to pejoratively call them
this is not some basement show with
two viewers uh interviewing some unknown
person this is fox news interviewing the
president of the united states hopefully
in a few months
this type of nonsense regularly coming
from the oval office emanating from the
oval office
will be relegated to the archives as
this happened and it's now in the past
rather than the day-to-day first here is
donald trump insisting
that this is going to be a rigged
election
and this has worked later in the program
i'm going to tell you about new polling
that confirms
this strategy from trump of saying it's
going to be rigged
it's not going to be fair it has worked
and it could
actually lead to chaos during election
day election week maybe we should be
calling it
i'll explain that later but here is
trump himself saying it
it's common sense and an absentee
ballot's okay where you send
in for a ballot they go through a
process and they send it to you and then
you send it
it's fine but these mail-in ballots
where they send
millions of them all over the country
it's a
it's going to be a rigged election and
this
country shouldn't allow it the courts
have to step in we're in many different
courts right now
if the courts don't step in the federal
courts you'll never know who won the
election just
so this is now on repeat this is just
he's saying it
multiple times a day trump pretending
first of all that there's a difference
in practice between
absentee and mail-in voting now every
time this comes up somebody will email
me and they'll say david
there is a difference between absentee
and mail in voting there's a difference
in theory
okay we could have a universal mail-in
voting system that would be different
from absentee voting
this time around when we talk about mail
in voting
what we mean is expanding absentee
voting which trump says is okay so that
everybody can get an absentee ballot in
some states this means sending everybody
a ballot
who's registered not dogs not
undocumented immigrants
in other states it means sending
everybody who's registered an
application for an absentee ballot in
other states it means
you still have to apply but saying i'm
worried about catching coronavirus would
be a valid reason to vote absentee when
traditionally in many
elections you would not have that
freedom you would have to
your reason uh for wanting an absentee
ballot would have to be justified in
another way so again trump pretending
there's a difference operationally
practically there is no difference
between mail-in and absentee
this time around and again trump does
allude to
the various lawsuits that he's filing
that is a real concern
that actually might work to gum
everything up
and we're going to talk about that later
as well in my segment on the
strategy to steal the election that's
coming up later
we'll continue in our sort of tour of
the horrors of this interview last night
here is donald trump complaining i mean
he's just so
whiny have you ever seen a supposed
alpha
uh complain and whine as much as donald
trump
saying he was impeached over his
so-called
perfect phone call disgrace they play a
much dirtier game
they'll impeach you over a phone call
that was perfect
nothing like that's ever happened before
they impeached me over a phone call that
was
absolutely perfect you couldn't have
made a better phone call there was
nothing done wrong with that phone call
and they play a much dirtier game a much
tougher game than the republicans
what do you think it's like being
hannity in these interviews i'm not
saying i
envy the guy and i'm also not saying i
feel bad for the guy i'm just saying
what do you think it's like
you're you're trump's friend hannity is
trump's friend um
hannity gives trump the softest of
softball interviews you can barely
you can't call it journalism you can
barely call it an interview
and trump still goes off the rails into
these disjointed aimless
tangents does hannity worry that like
wow i'm not even doing anything that we
would call journalism
and still trump doesn't look good and
then
somehow trump gets on to the topic of
ranting about pulitzer prizes and new
york times reporter maggie haberman
it's so weird what trump gets obsessed
with anonymous source is also a topic
take a look
they got it wrong and they got pulitzer
prizes the pulitzer prize is worthless
as far as i'm concerned because
when you have the maggie haberman's
getting a pulitzer prize and she got it
all wrong she doesn't i haven't spoken
to her
forever she's like my biographer like
she knows everything about me she knows
nothing about me
and they talk about they have sources
they don't have sources they're made up
they make them up in their mind they
have no sources i know when
there are sources but if you look at the
times and
i guess the washington post they got
pulled surprises and they were totally
wrong
imagine being so arrogant that you
think you know about any story a
newspaper publishes
whether there are really sources or not
now
for i'm not going to bore you again with
the confusion that trump has had for
years
about what anonymous sources are
remember
trump doesn't seem to understand the
difference between
a source that's anonymous in the sense
that a media outlet doesn't publish
their name
versus a source that is anonymous to the
reporter
okay in almost all cases when we talk
about
an anonymous source what we mean is the
reporter knows who the source is
but they are not publishing the identity
of
that source trump in many cases seems to
think
the reporters don't know who it is that
they are dealing with anyway
the level of arrogance and narcissism is
really something else and then here is
trump on the same
day that we have the first woman of
color as a presidential or vice
presidential candidate in the united
states
insisting he's done more more good i've
done more is one aspect of it but done
more good
for black people than anyone other of
course other than
abraham lincoln as he likes to say i've
done
more for the black community than any
other president
other than perhaps abraham lincoln now
here's just a final
little thing donald trump still
unable to say the word minneapolis
send in the national guard and solve the
problem like we did in minneapolis
just every interview i mean you have the
full spectrum
mostly you have a spectrum of jonathan
swann
pushing back in the axios interview last
monday night
all the way to on the other side sean
hannity
just letting trump rant and he never
makes sense he never looks good he can
never hold it together no matter what
the setup
no matter how freely and uninterruptedly
he's allowed to just say whatever he
wants
sometimes i actually think the
interviews where trump comes out looking
best and i alluded to this before
we've seen trump on fox news fox and
friends hannity
uh janine pirro we've seen the gamut
we've seen trump
in press briefings we've seen trump with
george stephanopoulos and with jonathan
it's always a disaster trump comes out
looking the best
where understand the level of
babysitting that has to be done by
by the interviewer trump comes out the
best on interviews for example with the
christian broadcasting network
now i'm not saying that when trump is
interviewed by cbn
he makes sense or he explains
policy or any of that what i am saying
is
just letting trump rant is it's bad for
trump he looks bad
cbn goes further on cbn the interviewers
will sometimes
rephrase what donald trump says
to make him look coherent that's the
level of involvement you need from an
interviewer even a friendly interviewer
to make donald trump look good it's not
just don't challenge him
it's don't challenge him and then
rephrase
his answers and respond to them like
he's being
insightful or intelligent or coherent
and the place that does that
is christian broadcasting network
there's probably some other i think that
he did an interview with some guy from
barstool
sports i didn't even know the guy but
that was a couple of weeks ago where
again
trump wasn't making any sense it was a
friendly interview
but the guy who interviewed portnoy i
believe his name was dave portnoy
dave portnoy if i'm remembering
correctly would actually
react and respond as if trump was making
sense and that's the degree of help
trump's trump needs in order to come out
of an interview
looking even semi-coherent it's
incredible
incredible that that's where we are
today let's take a quick break remember
that you can
follow me on twitch for uh
frequent live streams i will say at
twitch.tv
david pakman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so donald trump really may not need to
steal this election
we actually have the latest 538
projection which says that there's a 71
percent chance joe biden wins in a 29
chance donald trump wins you might
recall those are very similar numbers to
2016 and in 2016 of course it went in
the way of the 29
so we're going to deal with that
tomorrow but the point is trump
may not need to steal the election but
he's not taking any chances and he's
going to try
to steal it because why not if you can
do it why wouldn't you do it now without
redoing my previous commentary on the
race being closer
than these double-digit polling leads
suggest i'll remind you
when joe biden is up 9 in a poll
with a 3.5 margin of error that means
joe biden might only be up 2
in the popular vote with a popular vote
win of 2.2
in 2016 hillary lost so
i won't redo the entire commentary but
but the point is
when we see these leads for joe biden we
just we really have to assume nothing
and in fact the 538 forecast
which i'll go over in detail with you
tomorrow uh supports this
very very closely but what we should
know is this
is going to be an election that if trump
can steal it he's going to try to steal
it and we need to understand all of the
ways in which he's going to try to do
that
first of all donald trump has been
saying oh this is going to be an unfair
election
he's trying to make it unfair donald
trump has been saying this election will
be rigged
well he's the one trying to rig it trump
has been saying vote by mail won't be
reliable
he's the one trying to make it
unreliable by kneecapping the post
office and ryan cooper wrote a good
piece
uh this week in the week in the
publication the week
called donald trump is trying to steal
the election
and he outlines the various tactics and
strategies and approaches that donald
trump is employing and
there's actually a lot of them and
whether we can fight all of them at once
or how we do it is
is sort of the next question but we've
mentioned some of these before and i
want to put them together in a list so
first of all i mentioned this already
donald trump is trying to break the post
office the idea is
if people are going to vote by mail if
states are going to
expand absentee ballot access break the
post office so that it will be less
likely to succeed in polls we've looked
at
trump supporters among those planning to
vote in person
two-thirds are trump voters among those
planning to vote by mail
almost three quarters are biden voters
so you see right away
why trump would try to break the post
office that's one
strategy number two donald trump is
trying
to fine tune and find time
a stimulus a second stimulus so that
it will be best positioned to
essentially
buy votes and part of this is that
donald trump has said
uh i will defer payroll taxes
if he can right we'll see if he can
actually do it and
if you re-elect me i will make the
deferral
a permanent cut okay so he's effectively
saying
i will defer your payroll taxes for now
but unless you re-elect me when you file
your taxes next year
for this calendar year 2020 you will owe
the money you saved on the payroll tax
but if you re-elect me
i will make the deferral a uh
forgiveness
it it's trying to buy votes the right
loves to say oh bernie's trying to buy
votes with free stuff
like health care uh which would be paid
for through taxes
this is really trying to buy votes
saying i'll defer i'll save you some
money for now you're going to owe it
back
in apr by april 15th of 2021
unless you re-elect me okay trying to
buy votes number three
donald trump is trying to delegitimize
the election
to weaponize his followers taking to the
streets
after november third and it is working
we have a new poll which shows that
two-thirds of republican voters now
believe
that the election may not be fair i'm
going to talk about that later
in its own segment because it's so
important and and such a big deal and
really is the goal
of all of this donald trump is using
lawsuits
to try to turn the courts remember that
the courts
one of the biggest successes if you can
call it that one of the biggest
accomplishments
of the trump administration is mostly
thanks to mitch mcconnell's help
getting two supreme court justices
confirmed one of which should have been
uh barack obama's selection merrick
garland
and getting hundreds of lower court
judges confirmed
so donald trump is using lawsuits and
he's being open about it he's talking
about we've got this in court we've got
that in court
he's trying to use lawsuits to turn the
courts
uh in his favor
after the election and to try to prevent
vote by mail so there's two two sides to
this
use the courts now to try to block vote
by mail in different states
and start laying the groundwork to
if there's a challenge after the
election have
courts that maybe will be more
predisposed to rule in donald trump's
favor and you might remember that for a
couple weeks now donald trump has been
warning
it could take days it could take weeks
it could take months trump even said it
could take years to know who won
the november election that's not going
to happen but the point is
trump is trying to ensure that it takes
longer than it has to
with the lawsuits with the destruction
of the postal service
so on and so forth now again trump might
not need to do this stuff
trump might be able to win without
suppressing the vote
without turning to fraud but it's
possible
that the only way trump can win is with
these tactics
and this very well could end up being
the craziest presidential election that
the u.s will have ever had at least in
the modern political era
so what do we do come on you guys know
what we do you know what we do we vote
early ideally um they can slow down your
ballot
trump can slow down your ballot by
having
lewis the joy the new postmaster general
who is a trump donor
uh restrict overtime so that mail piles
up
in post offices look at trying to shut
down
some postal offices post offices or or
whatever
but if you mail in your ballot three
weeks early even if it's slowed down by
one two
three four days it's going to get there
and presumably presumably it's going to
be counted unless trump figures out a
way
to mess with the actual election and
voting precincts themselves
they can close polling places but if you
plan
to vote early you will be less affected
by that
so put the mask on or do the mail-in
thing
or whatever let's do this we know now
that it is biden and harris
could not be more different than trump
and pence for all of the complaints we
might have about a lack of perfection in
this ticket and
certainly there are many uh and be aware
of when and where you can start to vote
early i'm going to talk about that a
little bit in the next segment but
a lot that we can do and a lot that we
should be doing
okay i really need everybody to
understand this because this is so
important
the strategy by donald trump of saying
that the election will be
unfair and rigged is working
if it wasn't convincing anybody we could
ignore it it might be no big deal
but it is working donald trump has
convinced
65 percent of republican voters
that the upcoming election might not be
fair
this is a poll based on more than 44
000 u.s adults with a one percent margin
of error
now here's what makes this really tricky
65 percent of republicans question
whether the election will be fair
46 percent of democrats also aren't
confident that the election will be fair
but the devil is in the details because
the concerns about fairness from
republicans
are very different than the concerns
about fairness from the democrats and it
really comes down to understanding these
details
republicans who think the election might
not be fair
are falling for what donald trump has
been saying which is
mail-in ballots will be riddled with
fraud we won't know the election results
for a long time
they are rigging it that's what the
republican voters have fallen for
democrats on the other hand are worried
that
trump is making the election not fair by
breaking the post office by filing
lawsuits by trying to suppress the vote
so on and so forth uh preventing vote by
mail purging voter rolls
doing all of the things that republicans
have been doing for decades to try to
win elections by suppressing the vote
so these are not asymmetrical concerns
if you
glance at the numbers and you say okay
well it seems like republicans are
democrat
and democrats are basically in agreement
just to slightly different degrees
46 percent of dems think the election
might be unfair
65 percent of republicans no big deal
slight party difference
the reasons why they think there might
not be fairness are what is so
dramatically different
and what you have to understand in order
to really synthesize this properly
is the history of voter suppression
historically
democrats try to increase voter turnout
period
they just say if more people vote we're
better off in general
republicans have employed a strategy of
trying to
limit voter turnout in very particular
and specific ways
polling shows that it's trump
who will most likely or more likely need
foul play in order to win democrats
simply want the election to happen
they want everybody who wants to vote to
get to vote and they want every single
one of those votes to be counted
and it's true if that happens it's
better for joe biden we know that to be
true
the president is the one who realizes
that he might
need voter fraud and voter suppression
to win
as i told you in the last segment and
the scariest thing is that it's working
for donald trump our concern for a long
time has been
if it's close in november and trump
claims it was rigged and it activates
his followers
many with their guns to hit the streets
that could get very ugly and it could
happen very quickly
it could happen within hours of whenever
trump claims the rigging took place
so when we hear that there are you know
gaps in the confidence people have in
our voting systems
we can't forget that one side is the
side that tries to lower
turnout in order to win meaning a ton of
trumpists
are happy that the election might not be
fair
this has always been the point of
attacking it and this is why
it will continue unless we stop it this
is how it starts this is how you
weaponize people to hit the streets
maybe with guns to demand that you be
kept in power these are not
inconsequential or trivial matters
now what can we do if you want to find
out
how and where you can vote early check
out the page called
early voting by state on vote.org we're
linking to that page
in the description to the youtube video
for this story
and you will very quickly see that every
state is different here in massachusetts
for example early voting starts 11 days
before this is in person early voting
starts 11 days before the election
in michigan it starts 45 days before the
election we're getting close to that um
in florida it's early voting starts
at least 10 days before the election if
not earlier so
understand that understand what the
rules are
for voting absentee in your state you
probably in most states you probably
already
can request an absentee ballot i've
already done it i've received my primary
ballot for the september 1st election
and sometime after september 1st i'm
going to be receiving my absentee ballot
for the general election in november
understand all of these things
figure out how you plan to vote and then
let's activate
whoever we can and make sure that people
that are already on our side
plan to vote particularly when you know
trump wants to make it difficult to vote
but the reality is in most states it's
actually easier
than ever to vote with early voting with
expanded absentee ballot access
there's no excuse for not voting this
time around and many people
metaphorically this time around are
willing to
crawl over broken glass in over in order
to vote
some would literally do it i'm using it
metaphorically
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's just a little break from the from
the depressing politics
there's a really funny debate going on
in our audience right now
about whether i am providing too much of
a
setup for the video and audio clips that
i play on the show
here's a caller who thinks i should be
providing more of a setup take a listen
to this
hi david i'm calling in uh hit me
support of your uh usual format of
pre-loading us before you play a clip in
normal presenting of information
i love the idea of getting straight to
the content and then analyzing it after
and i respect those who
who requested that however when it's in
the case of
uh stuff coming out of the republican
the trump administration
uh trump itself it is so full of spin
and guest lighting which is kind of
abusive
that pre-loading us with information for
me
really helps relieve the pain
of uh of having to hear it and it also
it it is a a um like a vaccination
against the upcoming spin
it makes me look much more immune to it
when it actually uh
hits so i'm in strong support of your
pre
front loadings okay so
my idea for years has been i'm not like
uh
uh i'm not a video playback technician
the idea here is i'm giving you my take
and so
i try to prepare people for what we're
going to see and i
certainly give more of a lead up to
clips than some other hosts
might and it was deliberate i was doing
that on purpose
and every once in a while i would get
emails from people saying david
just give us the clip and then analyze
it so that you're not tainting our view
and and sort of priming us to believe
one thing or the other
then after tell us what you think and by
that time we'll have made made our own
uh sort of judgment of it and i tried
that yesterday and i've tried it a
little more recently
and i have to tell you overwhelmingly
overwhelmingly the reaction was no no
david don't just play the clips don't
you
don't be a video playback clerk
essentially
we are here for you to give us context
and the context before is actually
important so
this is not a huge deal it's an
interesting difference of opinion among
the audience
but a point taken and the response
overwhelmingly in the last 24 to 48
hours is
please go back to the old way tell us
what we're about to see and we can still
say we disagree with you
uh but we like to see what is your take
on what we're about to see so i'll
probably go back
in that direction we have a great bonus
show for you today one of the things i
want to talk about is
why is the post office being discussed
in business terms and what i mean by
that is
the post office is a public service and
president trump and his donor postmaster
general louis de joy
they're talking about it like it's a
business and it should be evaluated and
handled like a business that is supposed
to turn a profit that's not
actually what it's supposed to do and i
want to address that on the bonus show
we're also going to talk about the
reality that donald trump although he is
now
assailing the character of kamala harris
actually donated to her multiple times
we'll talk about that uh and then lastly
lebanon's leaders were warned in july
about explosives
at the port according to some documents
and we are going to
explore that in detail all of this is on
the bonus show
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpacman.com and remember august
23rd the 15-year anniversary of the
david pakman show
we will have a huge one-day membership
special to be notified of that special
get on my newsletter it's free at
davidpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link
right underneath this video